ich ärger mich die ganze zeit darüber
dass debattenkultur die werden unsere
demokratie haben also wirklich verfällt
und dass wir wirklich nur noch in
schwarz und weiß denken dass wir
wirklich nicht mehr an einander zuhören
können miteinander zu hören können das
ist auch nicht mehr miteinander reden
können und ich finde dass das auch viele
viele probleme wie panikmache alarmismus
etc einfach fördert und da müssen
einfach gegen arbeiten und wenn ich sehe
auch wie also ich arbeite ja nun in
einer koalition das sind drei
unterschiedliche partner und wenn wir
immer nur aufeinander eindreschen würden
und ein produktion würden im wirklich
nicht ein einziges gesetz machen würde
ich ein einziges gesetz für das land
gestalten können und ich glaube wir
müssen einfach wieder lernen miteinander
zu leben miteinander auch zu streiten
den streit auch anzuerkennen um daraus
wirklich gute schlüsse zu ziehen und ich
rede nicht von dem kompromiss auf der
kleinsten ebene ich rede von dem
kompromiss der uns weiterbringt und ich
glaube da sollten wir uns irgendwie
versuchen auf einem guten weg zu bringen
dass wir auch dort medienschulung gerade
bei jungen menschen etwa sie ran führen
dass man wieder miteinander redet und
streitet und nicht jeder gleich
stigmatisiert wird schon werden die
menschen demonstrieren gehen in diesem
land jeder darf in diesem land
demonstrieren weil er hat ja eine
meinung und ist doch völlig klar es geht
ja nicht uniform ist muss es geht ja
darum jeder der an der meinung hat kann
dafür natürlich auch gerade schneller
kann dafür demonstrieren gehen überhaupt
kein problem dafür sind wir eine freie
demokratie aber ich warne davor zu sagen
die leute die demonstrieren gehen sind
grundsätzlich alle schuldig oder die
entsprechende grundsätzlich meiner
meinung und deswegen muss ich sie
verteufeln also da waren nicht wirklich
vor dh sie finden die proteste auch
völlig in ordnung sind nicht gegen
protest in deutschland also die müssen
natürlich also ich hoffe dass es auch
proteste sind die
fundiert sozusagen auch begründet sind
ich glaube einfach dass viele menschen
einfach auch gar nicht mehr die
komplexität dieser zusammenhänge einfach
verstehen können wie lässt sich sagen
dass die demonstrieren dass dich alles
verstehen weil sie in die schraube noch
sind oder wie auch immer das wird damit
gar nicht sagen vielleicht nur damit
sagen dass wir durch auch im
leben reicht
sein beispiel beispielsweise ist wir wir
glauben eigentlich nur das was wir
glauben wollen das merken wir sehr viele
menschen ich lese immer nur das was ich
lesen will und dann lese ich dann immer
weiter ansteigen beispiel ein thema wo
sie sagt das mit eigentlich nicht
komplex genug gesehen naja also sagen
wir mal wenn wir uns über das bier
whiskey beispielsweise unterhalten das
infektionsschutzgesetz
corona und wenn wir da einfach hergehen
und sagen
was also wirklich erlebe was bei mir in
meinem büro passiert es mal mitarbeitern
wenn sie sagen sie sind für oder gegen
korona maßnahmen dann kriegen sie
mittlerweile von jeder seite tausende
vom innersten tausenden und didi rufen
sie an die legen ihm die leitung
teilweise lahm ich kenne das von meinen
twitter-account du kannst du nicht mal
nachlesen ich antwortete auch nicht mehr
drauf weil das sind übelste
beleidigungen verliert jede kurzen aber
dann haben wir ein problem in der
meinungsfreiheit in diesem land wir
haben kein problem mit der
meinungsfreiheit wir haben einfach
verlernt unsere meinung zu sagen und
zwar auf ordentliche art und weise und
darüber zu diskutieren
die findet es lohnt sich dafür zu
kämpfen dass wir wieder eine
streitkultur in diesem land kriegen ich
war dass er so eine sendung wie heute
ist bis zum beispiel wir
unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber wir
müssen erst einmal lernen das zu
akzeptieren und nicht den anderen gleich
in eine schublade zu stecken und sagen
also weil sie jetzt andere meinung haben
als ich mir
das meinungsklima denn auch mal anders
in diesem land also nehmen sie in den
letzten jahrzehnten eine veränderung war
ja ich nehme eine deutliche veränderung
war ich wollte mal was sagen zum
meinungsklima wie lange die diskussion
zwischen uns beiden meinen nachbarn und
mir hat gezeigt wie es sie in diesem
land läuft der hat nicht ein einziges
sache aber wenn gebracht bis auf eine
ist das falsch war er hat ihn so zwei
drittel seiner ausführung etikettiert
mich attackiert und mit adjektiven
belegt aufgeregt kämpferisch
krawallmacher das ist alles das üblich
und am ende ich hatte darauf gewartet
hatte mir af.de artisten haben sie
gesagt nehmen sie die an bürger machten
hfd nahestehend bitte kunden
konzentrieren sich auf wir erwarten dass
auf jeden ich habe was haben sie gesagt
ich nicht den wänden ich habe das nicht
legal sehen wir die leute interessieren
jaja hat aber gesagt aber darum gehen
dass es gar nicht für so ein typisch
linke argumentation
die regierung habe das mittel der
deutschen lebt unterhalb der star das
stimmt einfach nicht dieses rein gelogen
es sind 15 der deutschen die in prekären
verhältnissen ihren friedhof soll das
untere drittel der bevölkerung ist ein
drittel
deutsch kann ich auch noch also im
unteren drittel ist ein drittel ich bin
keine so guten 3
wir müssen wir jetzt einlass manchem
eines casinos in richtung außerdem dass
manche rapp
material brauchen wir brauchen also
ja also insofern ist was der daher recht
von der fdp das hier ist ein
paradebeispiel der vergifteten kultur
ich möchte meinen zur argument beiträgen
beitragen 2009 10 hat alles noch eine
studie über das mein allensbach ein
renommiertes institut zwei drittel der
deutschen haben heute bedenken ihre
meinung war dass bitte unsere eigentlich
zwei drittel entschuldigen sie bitte im
august 2009 10 erschienen es ist den
letzten tagen letzten erst eine neue
untersuchung gekommen die deutschen das
gleiche wird dabei stetig das ehrlich
gesagt uns die shell-studie muss hat
sich besser auskennen ist mit je
jugendstudie das heißt es gibt einen
bestimmten bereich von themen wo man
lieber das sagt aber dass man gesagt
wird und das ist kein demokratisches
bringt gesellschaft das ist der beginn
der unterdrücker gesellschaft wenn ich
heute höre dass sie nur bei missfallen
der nazi aktionstelefon eingerichtet
werden wo man leute melden kann die ihm
eine andere meinung zu bestimmten
beispiel das aus meiner sicht absolut
unmöglich
wird von fürsorge gruppen
leben
anderer meinung
eine mehrheit ist auch meine meinung
sagen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie
ja nicht mehr programm an dort ist er
deswegen reise viel geld er und klopft
und speicher kommen wir einmal wieder
abgeflacht irgendwie der debatte heute
sie sagen ja ganz plastisch sie fühlen
sich in ihrer meinung unterdrückt weil
sie nicht alles sagen dürfen
ich kann jetzt nicht mehr in diensten
wieder mal akzeptieren das kommt nicht
so gut an aber ich habe tatsächlich ja
erlebt man darf nicht frei äußern was
man so denkt ich mache das gerne
das ist mein aktuelles buch
arbeitgeber darf ich zu hause reden es
geht nämlich eigentlich darum dass
dienstliche geht's hier gar nicht so es
geht ja um ein thema das ich seit drei
jahren sehr prominent vertreten und auch
als einzige in deutschland was bisschen
traurig ist und eigentlich viel sagte
für unser land da ich nämlich jetzt
dieses buch im amerikanischen als
allgemein im angloamerikanischen bereich
vertreten und dort die reaktionen 180
grad anders sind und mir begeisterte
verein zuschriften romas eben tag ins
haus flattern